hey dalton you're a pre-product market
fit do you have five-year financial
projections that's a great example of
that financial projections may be a good
idea later stage
but to even ask me if i had financial
projections
i was like what's a financial project
this is michael cyber with dalton
caldwell and today we're going to talk
about why investors
including yc
can't fix their company for some folks
it's like telling them that santa claus
isn't real you know you're like they're
like hey we finally get some time with
you
you know no one wants our product
what should we do here's some here's our
designs can you help me design this so
growth takes off and i have to tell them
the unfortunate news which is
i have no idea
and like i went through this through two
when i was a founder that i really
believed
that once i raised from the top
investors they would tell me whatever
secrets they were holding out on the
world
what's unfortunate is that there are a
lot of investors out there who aren't
former founders right who haven't really
um
lived these mistakes themselves
and if you haven't been humbled by
having a crappy startup like we did that
failed a lot like we did
um
it's easy to sort of like
think your hot [ __ ]
it's easy to think that your advice can
make companies work
that like you are the magician
and
what's interesting is that over the
years
a lot of yc founders will kind of
start following the advice of these
people
and they'll make very very common errors
and you can almost track it back to like
oh i kind of understand the type of
person who is giving you this advice
because i see what you're doing now and
like this matches one-to-one so
one of the most common
types of investors is
the investor with the finance background
someone who's like never run a company
never operate in a company pure finance
when all you have is a hammer
everything's a nail and so
if
what you know is money the solutions
usually involve money so raising more
money spending more money
throwing money at the problem right hey
dalton you're a pre-product market fit
do you have five-year financial
projections that's a great example of
that financial projections may be a good
idea later stage
but to even ask me if i had financial
projections
i was like what's a financial project
like michael how how many years in your
startup did you learn what a balance
sheet and [ __ ] was
long time actually and i resisted it i
resisted it our ceo kevin was like this
is important for you to learn and i'm
like you know what's important for us to
learn how not to lose money every month
before we die
like and the balance sheet is not really
telling us that it's um it's that we
make no money and we spend money so
that's what's that's what the problem is
you know for these folks i get it right
you you spend time in spreadsheets
especially if you're doing stock market
investing or private equity investing
it makes sense that your weapon is money
and you move money around that's your
leverage point that's your point of
leverage what's the downside of
internalizing that too much man
i mean
we see this all the time which is like
scaling negative you could a unit
economics
or spending a ton of money in
advertising with ever ever worse
um payback periods or no payback period
ever
it's really like
getting people to work on things that
are not making their product good
yeah and i think whatever patrick
collison was talking about this when he
came to speaking of bats recently where
he's like listen let me let me be blunt
too many founders treat product as an
afterthought
they're basically trying to do financial
engineering and the product is like
delegated
i think what's also tricky is that like
this strategy isn't always wrong
like
for successful companies there is
usually a point where throwing money at
it is a good idea
it's just kind of knowing when to give
that advice and when not to
it's when you always give that advice is
when things get really tricky all right
here's the second type that's that's
common in the investing world the big
company exec
the person who's you know seen seen
companies at a thousand plus people and
have a lot of experience and have done
like great work in those companies and
now become investors
folks with big tech experience are
really great at taking a successful
product and scaling it further or
refining a product okay
it just
is pretty different when you were
employee number you know 100 or 200 at
airbnb or google or facebook than
employee number five and as we spoke
about in a prior video our our friend
and colleague paul buhit you know number
18 at google
had
was like the king of dirty hacks
in a lot of ways you know when we would
interview former googlers and he was in
the room he would
he wasn't on
he didn't love
some of the instincts of folks that it
was the same company that they worked at
but the the tactics that they brought to
bear when you were employee number 1000
to scale up
one of these core products was pretty
different than the folks in the first 20
employees and so generally with these
folks
it looks more like scaling a process it
looks more like scaling up hiring
and
kind of sometimes taking for granted
that getting any users at all is
really hard
like i talked to about folks a lot about
this in the batch man like
what failure usually looks like for a
lot of our companies is they get zero
real customers
yeah zero
it's not that the failure was they
couldn't get a series a it's that they
just like bombed like complete disaster
and so if you have too much of this
mentality of like big company pm
it doesn't even occur to you that you
can fail that badly
yeah what do you think i think it's
tricky because
all too often
this group of folks are giving founders
the advice of hiring executives
before product market fit it's like you
need to build up the company it's like
marketing doesn't work we need a
marketing executive like
like um
the the engineering team isn't
productive enough we need a vp of
engineering
and and more often than not in this
pre-product market fit phase the mistake
is that there's the wrong person in the
company not there aren't enough people
the mistake is like you've got an
engineer that no one wants to work with
or
no one's measuring any of the marketing
results right it's like those are the
mistakes not like you don't have a
department for it or an executive to run
it
whereas
we go right back to the first one right
when a company is scaling and growing
post-product market fit like hiring more
people is essential
it's like once again we get this weird
dichotomy
think about the first five employees of
facebook and the first five employees of
instagram before when it was started
before they got acquired the first five
employees of youtube when it was a
startup before it got acquired versus
the really awesome people post
acquisition who had to step in and scale
that thing those people are awesome
hallelujah they're super valuable and
if they weren't around on the in the
zero to one stage
watch out again what i'm saying like
it's a very different muscle to build
scaling instagram post acquisition if
you were on that team than being
getting the first 100 users when you
were the founder of instagram right
very and there's a whole lot more
actually supply and demand there's so
many more people that helped scale
instagram than there are people that
founded instagram yeah right
there's just a lot so there's
there's lots of folks that have lots of
experience scaling products
and it's you just don't meet as many
that did the zero to one yeah
so the next category is the
successful entrepreneur in the non-in a
non-tech industry
and and this is really common this is
really common internationally in like
new
founder ecosystems where like the people
funding them maybe didn't make their
money in tech
what's the common kind of advice given
here
yeah this one's tricky
um where if someone made all their money
investing in real estate or in
strip malls or franchise mcdonald's
franchises or something like just
something that is not remotely a tech
startup they will often ask for crazy
terms that would make sense if they were
investing in like a franchise store
um they may ask for more control
and they may be really stressed out all
the time that you're going to lose their
money and so a lot of the trickiest
investors is a nice way to say it that
i've seen
um the yc founders are like oh why did i
take their money it'll just be someone
who's totally well-meaning but they
treat this
like an investment in a subway franchise
and that you're the manager of the
subway franchise and they're gonna call
you and yell at you
or something that you're gonna lose
their money as opposed to letting you do
your tech startup and that's really just
like
they really these folks are like
you can't be mad at them they're just
taking the principles that they learned
to make their money
and applying them to a different
industry right and it's like totally in
some ways these are people you can be
mad at the least because it's like at
least they're they were successful
themselves and they're like taking
things that worked for them right like
they're not reading this [ __ ] on twitter
um
but it is tricky because like i think
what we've learned is that industries
are just different
like you know maybe there's some common
principles but like in general
software companies look really different
than a lot of other companies out there
so
all right here's the next investor type
the junior investor the person who just
got started
looking to make a name for themselves
still early in their career
oftentimes um
having to really have a win pretty
quickly to cement themselves in this
career
um what's the most common type of advice
that these people give
yeah i think this one is tricky i think
a good mental model is to put yourself
in their shoes i think when you're a new
investor or you're newly hired at your
job
you're not in a position of power inside
of the place that you work or you're not
in position power with your investors
because they want to raise money from
someone else
and so to show weakness or to like screw
up their first few investments
is very bad for their career and we know
lots of people that basically
don't last in the industry because their
first investments were bad like it's
kind of career suicide to become an
investor
not have any other track record and then
make some bad investments yeah like
you're not gonna make it okay and so
basically these folks
are very optimistic
that it's gonna work that you're gonna
make it work that you should totally go
raise more money
yes because they're they're kpis that if
you raise money and they can mark up
their investment it makes them look good
so they can go tell their colleagues or
their their investors hey i invested in
this company and it went on to raise
more money at a better valuation than i
invested at i'm really working yeah
right and so the thing to understand is
that's their kpi and so in your
interactions with them they will often
just
really encourage you to fundraise and to
keep doing that a lot and everything's
working great and you do have product
market fit and you should scale faster
yeah
right
and and it's interesting because
another example of like
they're not trying to hurt your company
like in many ways they're nice people
yeah in many ways they're like
some amongst the biggest cheerleaders
for your company
it's just that like your company at this
stage probably has some really broken
[ __ ] that has to be dealt with and so
unfortunately
it's harder for them to kind of go and
spend the time in the dirt with you on
that stuff
because it's going to kind of break
their illusion
and um
hey you know it's it is what it is it's
rough like if you're a company where it
doesn't make sense to raise for a very
long amount of time
it may be the right thing that you want
to do but may not
be great for them if their whole thing
is to prove that they're great investors
really fast so that they can keep
their jobs
so the next category investor we see a
lot is the influencer famous person
um
what do you when i think about this kind
of person this is the person that
would come to a yc demo day and everyone
would freak out to get them on their cap
table yes
they just yeah they just get you know
infinite access
um
how do you think that they try to
help founders who are who are struggling
i think that
you really understand distribution if
you're an influencer because that's your
game is building up your distribution
network which you can monetize a bunch
of different ways right if you have a
million
you know instagram followers or a
million tick tock followers you can make
money off that and you get it you're
savvy so i think these people are very
savvy and realize
they can kind of treat startups like
other
ad deals
of being like give me some stuff and
i'll promote you
and so a lot of times these folks will
like ask for advisor shares
or they'll ask they'll just ask for
things and again that's how they got big
they're good you know they know
they know what they're doing
um
and it can be so tempting to do it to
think that like celebrities
tweeting about your thing is gonna fix
all your distribution problems
and like maybe in some cases they do
but most of my experience both
personally and with founders and yc
is the founders kind of feel like they
got a raw deal on these and that the the
clicks they get from the from the posts
or whatever
were not as helpful as they had hoped
this is a nice way to say it and you
know what's weird about this dalton is
that the the best most reputable
influencers and famous people in tech
world they don't promise
distribution like they say i'll try to
help but like i think the founders set
expectations way too high like it's the
founder once again looking for the
silver bullet someone else solved the
problem for me
and um
man silver bullets don't exist all right
we got two more types here so two more
types
type one is other founders so this is
becoming a lot more common nowadays
right like
founders investing each other's
companies it's you know some people have
seen success doing this others not
but what's the advice that you know most
often you're going to get from another
founder
to help you when they're on your cap
table usually when you get advice from
other founders it's heavily based on
their personal experience
the
but like the downside of that is if
they're really if they really struggle
to fundraiser with fundraising
personally all their advice is gonna be
them basically telling you don't do what
i did
or if they struggle with distribution
all their advice is gonna be
around you know like they're almost like
they have a lot of feelings about what
happened to them again this is where
founders do dude like a lot of my advice
was heavily based on my personal
experience
and it only it took years of me working
at yc
to sort of
break out of that trap
which is to not be so autobiographical
in the things that i'm telling people
you know i think this is something that
like people don't understand
enough
is like how much we are learning from
the founders that we're working with and
how much we are
condensing their learnings and
delivering it to the next generation of
yc founders versus how much we're
condensing learnings
personally that we got in our own
companies
i think that's like very
counterintuitive to most people um
the last one is the extremely young
investor right the the
just out of college writing a check
sometimes this person's in college
writing a check
um and kind of trying to to build a
career
in our world different from the
this person often is different from the
like
junior investor because this person's
usually not working at a vc fund or
they're a big fun like that they're
usually kind of
a scout or some kind of in that kind of
role what's the what's the advice
they're often given
yeah i mean look these people are super
sweet and they're super exciting you
know to talk to i just think that like
the same way that the founder realizes
their job is to play the part of a
founder and so they like
watch movies about how founders are
supposed to act and like read books
about it and they sort of
are
being like am i doing it right am i a
founder now like
i think you kind of see this from these
investors where they just they read what
other investors
say and do and they sort of like say and
do whatever it is they read and so like
whatever the hot new trend is whatever
people are tweeting about whatever like
latest essay they've read they just sort
of like repeat that
and see if and hopefully no one notices
that that's what's going on
which is which is how people learn in
school right so it kind of makes sense
like it's exactly the same so
you know
one of the interesting things here to
kind of wrap up is that
we make mistakes like we screw up there
is a yc partner
common
bad advice kind of mode and um you know
we were talking about this before the
show
and i think you said it right which is
like
the kind of lean startup
don't hire don't spend too much money
like talk to your users
put a shitty mvp out in the world path
is the path that works for everyone in
all cases
i think sometimes we can fall into that
trap but there are many examples that
doesn't
apply right like
what are your thoughts on on where
yc partners ourselves we can get trip up
and give bad advice
yeah i think that
the biggest critique i would have of
ourselves
is that sometimes it works right out of
the gate
and sometimes you can spend two years
building a product in a cave and never
talk to a single user
and it's perfect
and you immediately get product market
fit
sometimes that happens
i think that we just we have we have
enough data points that it seems like
insane of us to ever recommend that
strategy statistically yeah like it's
like
it's like hey oh you have cancer oh well
you know if you you know go on a water
fast that might fix it like maybe
i think that it just feels a bit hard
for us to recommend
making a strategy
to not do those things but
we have enough data points of yc
companies we see companies that can't
bootstrap or can't launch an mvp and
have to go build something in a vacuum
for two or three years yes and sometimes
it works
yes
yeah right
the best yc partners are very careful
with how forcefully we give the yc
advice because like
the longer you hear the longer
you have a kind of running record of the
time i told someone to do it like this
and the opposite worked
yep and so you know honestly
but to me you know what the lesson is
there michael the founders that made it
work believed in themselves and they
knew that we couldn't fix it like they
actually internalized the whole meta
point of this video or at least what i'm
trying to get across with it which is
like you know they they took bits and
pieces
they they they took information from the
outside world but they took personal
accountability that they're the ones who
are gonna have to make it work
yeah and they weren't counting on
blindly following anyone is being the
way it ain't
right nope
and and especially including us yeah i
think that the big takeaway here is that
as a founder it's your job to figure out
how to best use these people who are
here to help you
all these investors who are here to help
you it's your job how to figure out how
to best use them they all have your
interests in mind
but none of us can tell you exactly what
to do to win
none of us
and like it's funny because at the yc
kickoff the first thing we say is that
you know we're experts in failure we
know a lot of paths to not take
but if you want us to sit next to you at
your desk and tell you everything to do
to win to become a billion dollar
company
we can't do it and we actually ask them
we're like hey and if you want to leave
yc right now
we'll
we'll take or give your shares back like
we don't want you to come in here with
any false pretenses like
this is a hard problem most people don't
succeed
and like you're going to be able to
deserve 99.9 of the credit if you figure
it out
because you figured it out
all the rest of the people around who
helped you they didn't figure it out
dalton before we close
you know we've talked about a number of
examples of when investors give advice
and it kind of pattern matches to where
they come from but might not apply to
you at this time
what are some of the pieces of advice
you've gotten from investors that have
really made a huge difference like what
what what is
what's been some examples of great
investor advice because you know i think
you and i both have these
i think
the best investor advice i ever got as a
founder is that i was swimming in my
head with too many ideas at once
and i had too much data
and that someone from the outside could
look at everything and be like oh
this is working
they could take they could take all of
this like consternation and like
complicated stuff
and like i can think of a couple times
in my life when someone was just like
this is working you should do more of
this
and they were right and it added a ton
of value or conversely
this is bad
you're failing
yeah and again i was full of excuse like
like my brain was full of like a
thousand different threads going a
different direction but to have someone
synthesize that into something very
simple
was super helpful dude
i got great advice like that when i was
a founder
number one number one piece of advice
we ever got was from you know someone
who experienced big companies guy named
gideon you and
we had just gotten justin tv profitable
and we were very proud of ourselves
um and we the first year we really tried
to monetize we made eight million
dollars in annual revenue which
i think now would qualify us as like a
decacorn or something
um
and he came to talk to us and he
basically said folks look you should be
happy congratulations but your company
sucks if you don't change stuff
it's all going to die and all the work
you put in so far no one's gonna
remember what you did
and what's great is like there was no
like and so you should do this it was
just more like
and that's that's my current status of
your company in a nutshell
and it's exactly what we needed to hear
we just like the best investors point
out the problem they don't give you a
solution they just point out the problem
and they it's true we knew it we knew
that was the problem too it's just when
someone says it to you you're like oh
crap but isn't that funny because again
like so many incentives in life are set
up
to be nice or to tell people that
they're great and they should stay great
and everything they're doing is great
and they're taking over the world but
weirdly again if i think back to the
founder advice that i got and same with
you it's actually when people were kind
of hard on us
yeah that that was actually what was
hopeful
yep right well you know it was crazy one
of the reasons why i think gideon felt
so comfortable giving that advice is
that he had no interest in investing in
us at all yeah he literally had no
interest
and you know that's a counterintuitive
thing right like wow it's like really
you can get a lot more honesty out of
somebody when they're not
financially incentivized to kind of blow
smoke up your ass to you know to say
nice things so
all right